>> Gillian: MEDIA CRITICS ARE
HAMMERING THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
FOR ITS COVERAGE OF THE
RECENTLY RELEASED EMAILS FROM
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
SOME ARE HAILING DR. FAUCI’S
HAILING FRANK HONESTY.
CRITICS QUESTION HOW THE MEDIA
HAS FRAMED ALL OF THIS.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" TWEETING
QUOTE ANTHONY FAUCI’S PANDEMIC
EMAILS FROM MARCH AND APRIL
2020 OBTAINED THROUGH THE
FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT
OFFER A PEEK INTO HIS WORLD OF
THE FRANTIC EARLY DAYS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS AND THEY DO
INDEED.
JOE CONCHA IS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND MEDIA COLUMNIST
FOR THE HILL AND WILL BREAK IT
DOWN.
THE FIRST QUESTION THAT NEEDS
TO BE ASKED HERE ABOUT THIS
TROVE OF EMAILS IS WHICH
PORTRAIT OF DR. FAUCI DO THEY
PAINT?
IS HE THIS RELUCTANT MEDIA HERO
THRUST INTO THE SPOTLIGHT BY
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP?
OR IS HE A VERY SAVVY POLITICAL
OPERATOR WHO SORT OF TOOK THE
REINS AND MANAGED WASHINGTON’S
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC?
>> WHAT I’M SEEING MOSTLY,
GILLIAN, INCREDIBLY IS THE
CONTINUED LIONIZATION OF DR.
ANTHONY FAUCI.
THE EMAILS SHOW FAUCI WAS
COGNIZANT OF A POSSIBLE LAB
LEAK AND ARGUED THAT RETAIL
MASKS MAY NOT BE VERY EFFECTIVE
IN PROTECTING PEOPLE FROM COVID.
MOST IMPORTANTLY IT GIVES TWO
EXAMPLES OF FAUCI SHARING
DOCUMENTS AS THEY RELATE TO
GAIN OF FUNCTION CONTRADICTING
HIS TESTIMONY TO SENATOR RAND
PAUL NOT TOO LONG AGO.
REMEMBER, FROM A MEDIA
PERSPECTIVE FACEBOOK CENSORED
ANY POSTS SUGGESTED THAT COVID
WAS MANMADE AND IT HAPPENED IN
A LAB.
MANY IN MEDIA LAST YEAR
PORTRAYED ANYBODY WHO SUGGESTED
THIS SUCH AS SENATOR TOM COTTON
OR DONALD TRUMP AS A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST.
WHAT IS SO OUTLANDISH THIS CAME
FROM A LAB WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
PRECEDENT.
SARS ESCAPED FROM A CHINESE LAB
AND ANTHRAX ESCAPED FROM A
SOVIET LAB.
WAS THIS REPORTING BASED ON
FEELINGS AND FAVORITISM OR
FACTS?
THE FORMER, GILLIAN.
>> Gillian: HERE IS ANOTHER KEY
QUESTION JOURNALISTS AND
PUNDITS HAVE TO ASK THEMSELVES.
HOW MUCH WIGGLE ROOM DO YOU
GIVE DR. FAUCI OR ANY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIAL WHEN YOU ENTER
A SITUATION LIKE THIS THAT IS
UNPRECEDENTED AND A GLOBAL
CRISIS, PEOPLE DON’T HAVE
ANSWERS, THEY ARE SCRAMBLING.
DO YOU MAKE SOME ALLOWANCES FOR
GETTING THINGS WRONG, FOR MAYBE
BEING WISHY-WASHY OR EVEN GOING
BACK AND FORTH ON THINGS?
YOU KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING, JOE?
HOW MUCH ROOM DO YOU GIVE HIM
HERE OR NONE AT ALL?
>> OF COURSE.
LOOK, IF THERE WAS SOME
CONTRITION ON DR. FAUCI’S PART
THAT WOULD BE ONE THING.
SOMEBODY WHO WANTS TO RELEASE A
BOOK IN NOVEMBER.
THAT BOOK HAS BEEN SCRUBBED BY
AMAZON AND BARNES & NOBLE BUT
IT TAKES OUT TO ME AND HIT ME
BEFORE I CAME ON THE AIR.
YOU HAD DR. FAUCI CHECKING IN
WITH CNN ANCHOR CHRIS CUOMO ON
A NIGHTLY BASIS WHILE THIS
PANDEMIC WAS RAGING.
LET ME GIVE YOU THE QUOTE FROM
CUOMO TO FAUCI IN APRIL OF 2020.
I’VE SPOKEN TO YOU ALMOST EVERY
DAY AND YOU HAVE BEEN CALLING
ME OUT OF PERSONAL CONCERN TO
MAKE SURE I’M OKAY AT 11:00 AT
NIGHT WAITING FOR MY SHOW TO
END AND SUNDAY MORNING.
WHY IS DR. FAUCI DURING A
RAGING PANDEMIC CALLING A
DEMOCRATIC ACTIVIST WHO PLAYS
AND ANCHOR ON TV ON A NIGHTLY
BASIS?
IF THAT WAS HIS PRIORITY I GIVE
HIM ZERO WIGGLE ROOM.
IT SHOWS HE WAS SEEING THINGS
THROUGH A POLITICAL PRISM AND
2/3 OF AMERICANS AGREE WITH ME
ACCORDING TO A RECENT RASMUSSEN
POLL.
>> Gillian: IT WOULD BE NICE TO
SEE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS AND
POLITICIANS STOP WITH THE
MULTI-MILLION BOOK WRITING